so there's a lot of people who've come
onto the podcast and various
conversations talked about this idea of
kind of an evolution so whether it's an
athlete a creator whoever
right basically it's like you do what
you do so if you're an athlete you play
a sport if you're a creator you create
content
then eventually it got to the point
where uh maybe i don't want to take the
advertising dollars of a sponsorship
maybe i'll just take like half in
equity right so i'll earn equity uh
eventually i became okay maybe i should
actually put money forward and invest
uh now what we're starting to see i
think is more and more um
you know creators and athletes and
people just with audience say wait a
second maybe i actually should like
start a company right and how do i go
partner up with an operator
uh and then i think kind of like the end
goal for some of these people is like
this holding company right where you can
invest
you can own assets you can kind of do a
whole bunch of different things and
you know people will debate where we are
along that journey but that just kind of
feels like the trend
absolutely it feels like you guys saw
that early and stepped in and said look
we can help you negotiate your contract
but that's kind of the table stakes
of what you're trying to do it's less of
like an
athlete manager sports manager and it's
more of like a business
confidant or a business partner to some
degree is that fair to kind of
to categorize it no i think that is fair
and you know
something i touched upon in that prior
topic we just talked about
um that speaks to this is partnership um
and the fact that when our clients are
done playing
our job is not done so um you know we're
a young agency so we only have so many
players that are done playing you know
but
um you know guys that have you know
finished their careers
we're still involved in their lives
we're still partners and advisors in the
things that they want to do and i think
it speaks to that point where
when we sign a client to vaynersports
the idea is that
yes we're in the business of
representing great athletes so yes their
their athletic talents are foundational
to the partnership
but it is a partnership not a
transaction and
sports are unpredictable if something
doesn't work out
that doesn't mean we're gonna stop
picking up the phone um and so
and the idea is that what we're trying
to do and what we're trying to
incorporate is that
the best time to network as a pro
athlete
is when you're playing the biggest
mistake that former players have made
and i've had numerous conversations like
that is that
they assumed that they could get to the
business stuff
when they were done but the problem is
when they're done
depending on how their career went um
they're just not as relevant as they
once were
and gary and i talked about it like gary
before vaynersports existed
would clear his calendar if a new york
jet or a new york knick said hey
i want to come sit down with you talk
shop but if they were
three or four years removed like
it's kind of like what have you done for
me lately kind of thing and not that
gary would ignore them but
he just wasn't as excited to take that
meeting and that's the reality of it and
so
we we always tell our guys we encourage
our guys that yes you know you have a
lot on your plate
but if you just got drafted you're hot
right now we can't and yes we believe
you have a great career but we can't
predict that you might shatter an ankle
you might
something may happen right and so um
we're always encouraging our team to be
active and network and
increase their exposure to things while
they play so that when they're done
playing they can really go full steam
ahead and not have to start from scratch
how much of the um kind of
sophistication that you guys have
uh on the business side ends up actually
uh informing or changing the way that
you negotiate contracts so for example
for an athlete that says
hey i'm going to make 100 this year
right and 20 if it's going to come from
my contract but 80 of it's going to come
from endorsement deals and businesses
and investments and other things
does that actually impact it all the way
that you negotiate the player contract
or those
two things separate you just kind of
have a holistic plan
you know it's a little bit separate um
primarily because there's
just all these rules and regulations
that dictate
what can and can't be done from a player
contract so
i think that yes we can borrow from our
business experience and things of that
nature but
um i will say that the collective
bargaining agreement um
limits you know some things that we can
and can't do
and that goes sport by sport got it
that's fair um
and i don't know if you maybe you don't
want to name names or something but
maybe give like an example of
uh when you guys talk about what you do
with the athletes
outside of those player contracts like
what's an example whether it's through
an endorsement deal
an investment a business just to give
people a sense of like
hey this is what some of these athletes
are actually doing off of the field
while they're playing
yeah i'll give you an example uh a
recent one
um or relatively recent but i think it's
perfect and speaks to just
our approach uh we represent a guy named
derek morgan
derek had a great nfl career
we represented him for his last two
years in the league
played nine years was with one agency
first switched to another and then
landed with us
and um by the time we started working
with derek he was really
established you know he did really well
he was a former first round pick he
signed a nice second contract
and you know years eight and nine
were kind of accelerating the idea like
he had already started kind of exposing
himself to more he got his mba
as part of a program that miami offered
he did had done some private investing
um and then you know that kind of made
itself selecting
why we were such a good match for one
another um but
you know i think him partnering with us
was yeah maybe i'll do one final
contract maybe i won't
let me ramp up while i'm playing and
still active to get a few things going
and so one of the things that um
i'm proud of is uh first and foremost
derek and his family are vegan so
derek's vegan
his wife charity is actually a chef and
vegan herself they raise their kids
vegan
and so one of the things that we helped
to do was um
you know charity is this amazingly
talented and amazingly charismatic
individual
with a real work ethic and she was ready
to kind of now that the kids were
getting a little bit older and derek's
career was kind of settling in
she wanted to um take the bull by the
horns and build a personal brand around
her
her cooking and and her vegan lifestyle
and so we helped charity launch
her uh personal brand you know designed
her logo built her website got her up on
instagram
walked through content creation
strategies this and the other thing and
charity has done extremely well and you
know we helped her get it started but
she really ran with it and saw the
opportunity
um and then derek um you know
when looking for endorsements we really
doubled down on
who he was you know he said listen
i've done well playing football of
course
getting a 5 10 15 000 endorsement deal
nobody's going to turn that down per se
but the same token i have the luxury of
kind of picking and choosing what i do
based on my own
beliefs and values so one guidance he
gave me and i'll never forget it was
like
i will never endorse something that i
wouldn't from a food perspective
that i wouldn't let my kids eat so if a
company came
and he wouldn't feed that brand to his
kids he's not taking their ten thousand
dollar easy check for an instagram post
so i took that to heart and um you know
through
a network that the morgans had through a
network that we had
uh we circled beyond meat as a perfect
opportunity
for both derrick and charity and so we
did a deal there
um it was not a cash endorsement it was
an equity-based endorsement over a
period of time
and i think where that really worked out
well was you know i sat in the driver's
seat with them negotiating the paperwork
and i think our my experience
and the lawyer that um gary and i use
for all our venture capital related
activity who supported me in this
negotiation on behalf of the morgans
all that experience and gary doing
personal uh advisory type deals
deals with startups where they use his
brand image and likeness and things like
that
i think i don't think there was anybody
more qualified to get the morgan's the
best negotiated
uh advisory equity barter type deal for
a brand like beyond meat than us and um
you know the best part was
beyond meat continued being successful
they eventually ipo'd
um and the morgans did a lot better
taking equity as opposed to a small cash
deal there
and i actually remember when i think
he's with the tennessee titans like at
one point
uh his wife by accident i think had
convinced like half the defense
right they were basically eating you
know vegan uh
and there was articles literally written
about the fact that uh you know
here's one of the biggest baddest
meanest defenses in the nfl and
you know nobody's eating any meat you're
exactly right yeah
it started because charity was uh
basically meal prepping for derrick
because derek would go to the facility
and a lot of the food there just wasn't
what he was trying to eat and so
he had this food and then one of his
teammates was like hey that looks really
good like can charity maybe hook me up
one of those
he tried it he loved it i think he ended
up being 11 of the 53 titans primarily
on the defense
were vegan for that season two two three
years ago that's
20 of the team vegan it was crazy it was
pretty cool